let's get into this week's audience
questions really good questions I
actually got something like 50 or 60
when I tweeted hey we're building up our
list of questions to answer in 2019 send
me your ideas or whatever a lot of
really really good ones want to start
with three that we picked out for this
week first one is hey David you have to
follow news and politics closely because
of what you do is following news and
politics that closely toxic and bad for
your health
I think it kind of is in a way I mean so
here's the thing my there's people in my
life including my mom who loves to talk
about politics who get a little bit
annoyed with me when I will go over when
I visit Western Massachusetts to her
place for dinner or meet with other
people and they say hey look did you see
what Trump is doing or whatever and I'm
fatigued but I don't want to have that
conversation and depending on who it is
I'll be more or less polite but to my
mom I'll say listen I do this stuff all
day for my job I'm out here visiting I'm
sort of like on vacation I don't really
want to talk about politics right now
and then of course after we argue about
that for 15 or so minutes we move on to
a different topic and I am sort of self
selecting out of political discussion
and conversations in almost all
circumstances other than when I'm doing
the show and preparing for the show
because I think that there is a certain
level of toxicity and either there's
sort of sometimes two opposing views on
this issue there's those who say
everything that is happening in news in
politics is of utmost importance and we
need to be keyed in include into it a
hundred percent of the time the other
side is the movement that says listen
it's not even worth paying attention to
the day-to-day of the news and what
takes place take a bigger look take a
six-month a perspective or a year or a
five-year perspective on what it is that
really matters I tend to be in the
middle I actually do think that there is
value to being aware of what it is that
our elected officials are doing on an
ongoing basis because if you're taking
the one-year perspective you are
selecting out of even potentially
influencing what the outcomes are of
what our elected officials are doing if
you're not even hearing about stuff
until months or a year after it happens
that being said
what I do is during the weekends I stop
watching news I stop reading news I stop
paying attention to what's going on
politically and then Sunday evening when
it's time to get ready for the Monday
show I start paying attention again and
I'll do a bunch of reading and see what
happened and start thinking about what I
want to cover on the show but I do think
that the nonstop exposure to anything
right even if your field is I don't know
if you teach accounting you you can't be
reading and talking about and doing
accounting all the time there needs to
be a break from that and I think that
both for people who are working in the
field like me and people who aren't and
are just observers of what's going on in
the world you've got to have a break
because otherwise it does get toxic I
think that there there probably is some
negative health effect to it and the way
I do it is I really only talk about
politics on the show I don't engage
almost at all in political discussions
with friends or with people who meet me
and find out what I do or much to the
dismay of my mom when I visit her yeah
even with her and I think that it's good
for everybody to take some coordinated
and and deliberate breaks from this
stuff